[Music]
hello everyone thank you so much for
being here today we're very excited to
see all of you here we're also very
eager to share with you our perspectives
about how to better manage your VM
instance my name is Sophia yang product
manager from the compute engine team
join me today are two of my co-workers
Karin and the VP who will help with some
where awesome demos so let's get started
when talking about running workload on
compute engine VM instances are really
at the heart and center of everything we
want to make sure you have the right
instance to run your job but also you
don't pay more and that's exactly the
first section we're going to be talking
about how to tune a VM instance so that
you have the best price performance next
we're talking about scaling most
workloads are now done which is single
VM instance how can you stick scale up
and down quickly that is the second
section will be covering posted tools
and a demo to show you the performance
we can achieve third backing up no
critical workloads can be done without a
good backup and recovery story and in
that section will help brand new
features to share with you to help you
better back up your VM instance and last
but not least secure how can you make
sure your you can manage the access
control to a VM instance so that's your
data you the environments are protected
and I Google security and privacy is
always our first priority right there
we're gonna share you some tips and a
new features about how to better control
the security and to secure a VM instance
first let's talking about tuning picking
the right VM instance so if you were
gonna ask me what is the red VM instance
for me then I can tell you that cuz I
have to ask you back what is a workload
looks like the right answer is the VM
instance size always depends on workload
so let's first look at the popular
workload running today in cloud
here just a lease of them and the list
goes on on basically a Google wonder
stand customers comes with a diverse set
of workload they all have diversity
requirements and a way are providing a
wider range of selections machine types
and VM instance and features to make
sure we can meet all your workload
requirement here just overview of what
the general categories of the machine
types were offering at Google we have
general-purpose memory optimized and the
shared course within each with each
family we also allow great flexibility
so that you don't have to think too much
on the constraints in terms of what you
should do in order to utilize certain
features what do I mean by that
for example let's right dive into the
general purpose machine types which is
our most popular machine type within a
general purpose pool will have three
families standard hand memory and high
CPU they are really designed to be
suitable for mo majority of your work
clothes so if you have the web server
you're trying to host the CIC D workload
you're trying to run chances are you can
find that the best suited machine within
this general purpose machine type
they're highly available across all our
regions and songs and they just mention
just remember I mentioned that they are
very flexible to use for example you can
attach localizes DS and the GPUs to all
of them unlike at other cloud providers
you have to think about our what size or
what generations that have to use in
order to for example use GPUs Google
general-purpose machine types you can
attach GPUs and localizes these all of
them better than that we also allowed a
wider range of Core 2 GPO ratios for
example at Google if you only need a one
core VM to to to a job but you would
like to have four GPUs to have a better
parallel computing you can do that
combination but not like other cloud
providers you have to have a much bigger
VM you ought to have a 4 GPUs it within
a predefined families most might all the
machines comes with one true
all the way up to 96 course so the next
very natural question will be say I
picked the 8 core machine how can I make
sure I'm maximizing all the compute
power how can I make sure I'm utilizing
all the money I'm spending and that is
an excellent question
in fact right scale recently did a study
and showing the estimate about 35
percent of cloth spending are all wasted
why wasted it just as an example I
mentioned you have an equal machine
right but a workload actually probably
only need six cores so there's a two
course I wasted another more extreme
example what if your workload need them
say 18 course but so 16 core machine it
wouldn't be enough while the next in
life you need to jump to you will be 32
cores so that will be almost double the
compute power you need so what your
options are there you can one pay the
double the money and so that you have
the maximum performance or your rewrite
your code or architect so that you know
your workload around could are fitting
better in the 16 cores know them ideal
options right and in fact all the cloud
providers know that not all the
predefined machine size can fit all the
workloads best but why they haven't done
anything yet the truth is the course you
are now using that's a green use for the
cloud provider because they can then
sell that to other people right but I
Google it's different we want you to get
exactly what you need without paying any
more and that is why we offer custom
machine types as a name suggests you can
customize the number of cores and
memories you cycle as you want with all
the flexibility you want waiting custom
machine types you can even achieve
higher memory to sleep your ratio
compared to general purpose machines
this is a great use case if you have
certain say licensing requirement if
your OS or application providers say
charging you based on number of course
you have so you want to kind of be
conservative there but you also want a
large amount of memory to maximize your
workload performance and you can do that
with extended memory
within the custom machine type family to
get started with custom machine types is
very easy just define the number of
cores and memories you need as an
example shows on the screen you can in
this example you create a new VM with a
custom machine type you can also update
an existing machine type machines to a
newer much VM shape just by stopping the
VM first as mentioned general-purpose
machine types is the most popular
machine types I Google+ the custom
machine type they should be able to
achieve the performance you want with
most of your workload requirements and
in fact more than 99% our customers
today are running on these custom
machine type plus the general-purpose
machine types and next let's see some
other options and the features you might
be to use it utilize to maximize your
workload performance the next one wanna
touch about is a preemptable viens what
they are they are a latest short-lived
low-cost viens how short-lived they can
only run up to 24 hours and that is not
if not Google preamp to you before that
Google my preamp to your VMs and anytime
with the 30 seconds notification so it
work a little better be pretty robust so
that you can handle that kind of
preemption and what is the plus side the
price you can save to up to 80 percent
compared to the listing price for
regular VMs another very powerful thing
to realize you can make any machine
types available at Google as a
pre-emptive of VMs you can just change a
setting a property with within the VM
instance make it a preemptable and there
you have it they are really suited for
say you have you have fault-tolerant
workload as a bad job or media rendering
genomic kind of jobs or shore-leave the
jobs there are not very suitable if you
have a job that you have a certain
deadline say in the next hour you want
to run a business report we don't
recommend you to run a pre-emptive movie
ends
next memory of divine sabaeans we know a
lot of interpretation your data center
to UM true cloud we realize one of the
biggest challenges to move those large
in-memory databases like ICP HANA a lot
of times because they couldn't find a
suitable hardware on cloud that they can
run your big memory machines customers
are forced to set up this Highbury
environment because they already moved
their applications web servers and to
the cloud yet they have to leave their
memory optimized VM behind cuz they just
couldn't find the right thing in a cloud
well if you are one of those customers
you'll be happy to find out that Google
offers the memory optimize the VNS which
can provide you up to three points to
refer a two terabyte memories that is a
lot of memories within the memory
optimized VMs will have a four machine
types as you can see and you can achieve
as high as 24 gigabytes per CPU ratio
and you might be thinking oh these must
be very expensive well they probably
more expensive than the share course or
one core VM but if you look at that
price per gig ratio they are actually
the cheapest among all of our machine
types so there are also very cost
effective so if you are one of those
customers you have a big you know you
memory database like I say P HANA you
wanna run now you never have to leave
them behind
well-well move all the workload on cloud
so go ahead try those memory map
optimized VMs and if you miss the news
from last week we're happy to remind you
that we just made this memory of mice
VMs to eat generally available for you
well after talking about memory
intensive workload let's talk about
compute intensive workload last february
also next Google announced the general
general availability of skylake CPUs
which made us the first ever cloud
provider supports the latest Intel
processor
skylake benchmark shows if you enable
the advanced instruction avx-512 you can
achieve the flow they can double the
floating-point calculation compared to
the previous generation so it's a super
powerful if you have a high compute
intensive workload they are perfect for
a scientific modeling 3d rendering and
in order to utilize the this you know
there's like this sky like CPU you can
utilize our mean CP apply form selector
function within a VM instance as the
example shows you can just define say
means if your platform equals to
skylight intel skylake then Google will
make sure your VM you land on a hardware
that has has skylake or even later
generations when they're available all
right since we're talking about a use
cases of customers we have seen another
common use cases is that especially from
certain verticals or industries like
finance health care the customers have
regulations you need to meet in terms of
where they can place the VM instance and
if you are one of those customers you'll
be happy to find out Google offers so
tenant nodes which are physical servers
dedicated solely for you you for you to
use so different from regular VMs where
you have to share the physical hosts
with other customers you can achieve
performance isolation so that you can
have as you have this whole server
dedicated just for you to get started
it's very simple just create a certain
and group group using this template and
then you can schedule VM instances unto
those so tenant groups in terms of where
the VM will be placed placed we have a
great flexibility offered they are two
so you can obviously directly explicitly
tell us where the group you want a
target or you can use labels and labels
lectures so you know to utilize that you
will first define labels for those
groups and you can have multiple labels
for each group and then we're scheduling
the VMS you're targeting those labels to
say you can say
place this VM on a group that is the
environment equals to test and a team
ICO's
a in Google will find the best place for
you that means suppose
or you can use ant affinity you can say
place this VM in a group of a but
environment does not equal to production
so you will you achieve that both
indefinitely an affinity with our labels
design which is very unique and flexible
furring last point I wanna mention about
so tenant is you can also mix different
shapes of VMs on to the same host again
at Google we always think about your
need we want to give you the max
flexibility also allowing you to best
utilize all the resources guards without
any artificial constraints what is
making better today will let you know
that the so tenant knows gonna be
generally available for you in August
that's really just next month alright we
have talked quite a bit about different
VM types machine types and features you
can utilize to tweenie other to best
achieve your price performance so I want
to make sure you guys let's do with me
so here's a quick overview of for the
things we already talked about and
actually I would like to ask the
audience some questions since we're all
so close just making sure you were
paying attention Trey so given the same
machine type which one saves you the
most money great yeah from two VMs right
let's say what if you have a sa P Hana
word what machine have probably the best
for you my resumes are great let's try
the last one what if say you don't want
your via you want to schedule VM to
somewhere that you don't have neighbors
you don't know great which is general
gonna be journal available for your next
month alright next let's move on to the
second point
scaling most people here don't just
wanna run single VM right how can we
quickly scale up and down so that got
your workload then we're gonna cover
that in this section we're gonna first
to tell you two tools that you can
utilize and then have a great demo for
you so first let's talk about the two
tools you can use earlier this year we
made this feature available for you that
is about creating
is from template disallowing you to
great use cases one is you don't have to
create a VM instance from scratch
anymore so what you can do is that you
can create a template you know define
all the images you want to use you know
disks et cetera and then quickly
duplicate VMs from there another use
case we have actually learned that is
from IT admins that they often wanna
issue some recommended shapes and VMs
who their developers using approve the
image they want you know using these
kind of subnets or firewall rules they
want so how to kind of pass down this
requirement easily they can create those
instant template so that there are
person know the exactly where they
should start another thing to mention if
needed you do can override the
properties within the instant template
when you're creating this VN so again
great flexibility for example in this
example in a screen you are providing a
source instant template yet you're
overriding the metadata value to be a
new value so that is to achieve is
exactly what you want next if you prefer
Google to manage the VMS the group of
VMs for you to scaling up and down for
you then you can utilize our manage the
instance instance group offering there
are two modes you can use one is fixed
size say you define a hundred vm geo
group and Google will maintain make sure
we maintain a hundred for you and do the
health check if we realize any VMs and
healthy you can take it down and bring
up a new one for you under the mode is
auto scaling mode you can most likely
connect that to a load balancer and we
can scale up and down based on work
based on traffic an original fill over
cuz we support post zoom no manage the
instance group and original so if
utilizing the original managing this
group it can avoid a salmon sooner
fellow its own low voltage and if you
wanna learn more about this manage
instance group there's a session
tomorrow for you that you can attend
this can be delivered by my coworker
McCullough alright so as we talked about
talked about that the features use to
help you scale up and down
I think another common concern from
customers will be wow I have to
screw up and not this many VMs you know
very quickly so what kind of performance
Google deliver and if you're one of your
customer had that kind of question
you'll be happy to find out Google has
excellent performance especially in
terms of bringing up viens a group of
them as Gunnar said it Google has
exceptional fast VM provisioning time
also here's another quote from our
customer saying they think and waiting
to you Google is the best cloud platform
because the greatest ability and the
performance all right so we have analyst
report
you know customer code to prove my point
but what is making it even more
convincing wouldn't you want to see how
quickly we can bring up VMs in real life
so today I would like to invite my
coworker current here to give you a live
demo to show you how quickly we can
bring up VMs up and down all right let's
switch you to the demo source so for the
demo we have prepared instance template
specifies a machine type weight one core
and we created a management group in
Europe the European zone and we're gonna
scale this 5050 M
you wanna see more that's 300 okay do
you go to the website so this is this is
the console for managing instance groups
and we're gonna update the existing
instance template and change the number
of instances to be 100 and the VMS that
are gonna start up they have a image and
have a startup script that as soon as
they come up and boot they will ping the
web service that we deployed and the web
service will visualized
the master node of the the VMs that are
coming up so this is the web service
that detected that instance group is
scaling up and it times up calculates
the time it takes to receive messages
from the slave nodes as it receives them
so during this period the yams are
allocating computer resources IP
addresses and they are doing booted
program to the network and then they
start thinking the web service and as
you can see within like 40 seconds with
that all the VMS
started booted and running the customer
workload which in case in this case is
pinging the master not Wow 41 seconds
100 notes
I feel the longest wait is actually the
VM provisioning time where as you
mentioned allocating ip6 cetera tell
them that maybe we can try something
bigger and spin up more VMS like go
higher number how high you guys want to
see them 1000 did I hear 1,000 10,000
should we put 10,000 lowdown to our
production system we can do that but it
will probably take a little bit longer
and bore you guys so let's try the
thousands sure but before start let's
have a guess
well 100 is 41 seconds so how long
should it be 1000 B people are good at
math right but let's see if we can do
better than linear scaling by the way
that's a right answer I think 41 times
10 ok so there are instances now scaling
up 2,000 B ends and we already see the
VM showing up in the management group
and see what the web service is
for the country started and we're trying
to see if we the timer is started but we
already have the hundred VMs from the
previous action so we're gonna wait for
another 900 VMs well already cut seek
osmium stars coming in as we speak
sure the VMS that are already running
the customer workload they pink the
masternode so that's the custom startup
script at the VM cos and that's how we
detect that the VM is already up and
running with the user code well the
number of clicks are going up
Oh is he already 400 it's real demo Oh
like this is real them oh yeah because
this depends how busy the the cluster is
so there is also other customer
workloads running in European zone that
are accessing so yeah we have customers
in Europe a lot of them yeah that shows
our compute power a people don't stop
computing and great I think less than
two minutes to thousands a lot a lot
faster than the 400 seconds ray yeah
that is so awesome to see so as it's
important to provision the VMs fast it's
also important for the were close to the
provision the VMS and that's usually in
the scenarios where you want to update
your cluster tear down the existing
games and start new ones so we would
like to also demonstrate the deep
provisioning and deleting the VMS so
I'll go ahead and remove all the VMS
from my instance group precise it to
zero and in this case I'm not gonna look
just the shutdown script of the VMS
because the first thing that we do in GC
we stop the guest OS from running user
code but then it takes some more time
until we release all the computer
sources IP addresses and
the resources from the our database so
what the web service does it monitors
all the VMS in managed instance group
and make sure they are fully dilated
before it showing as clear down in this
visualization so like if we go in this
page you will see some some of the VMS
are being deleted and they probably
already stopped running the workload but
we still have them here we already got
several of the VMS deleted but it will
take a little bit more time to tear down
all of them but we can see we are still
already start getting them and I think
what in addition to what you mention the
use case that I can see I see these or
updates that you want to kind of quickly
tear down your cluster so that you can
start the next one also or one I remind
you you don't start paying until the VMS
are stopped or deleted so being able to
do so quickly for a large amount of VMS
also saves you a lot of money
so the question is a deleting them do we
have like a kind of undo option to cache
them for a little bit now when you
delete their parental deleted like if
you the little the end pair disks are
not necessarily deleted it's an option
that you can specify and we can delete
just the VM but disks will stay longer
yes well we're almost done there yeah
yeah all right only 65 left and seems
like a little over two minutes yeah I
think pollution took a little longer
than the two minutes we've got for
creation all right it's almost done I
think the next i refresh great 0:07 I
think if you try to cheer down existing
cluster and then provision that from
scratch it will take you less than five
minutes to do that with thousand VMs
great thank you so much thank you
isn't that amazing thank you so much
current and I think I forgot to mention
currents one of our tank technical
leader to make all this possible to make
the spinning up-and-down possible
quickly thank you all right so can we
switch back to the presentation all
right so next let's talk about backing
up as mentioned no matter you have this
database I'll share the file system
whatever the important workload you want
to have a great backup story to
periodically backup a data to make sure
you have a great checkpoint to go back
right so in this section I'm going to
tell you two tools you can use to better
backup your VM instance the first one is
use instant template which is similar as
we attached earlier to quick we mention
about using instant template create moto
VMs and in this case you can also use
the other which is a creating isn't
template from the existing be
why does it useful because we have heard
of many the use cases especially the
developer trying to portrait have
something starting off from a new
project
they often started with a VM and then
tweak it to exactly what they wanted
maybe at the disk
you know maybe change the network etc so
once they are done to tweak get to
exactly the Golden State they may not
actually need a VM you know because of
prototyping but they want to make sure
they save the configuration so that they
can go back to recreate that and if you
have that kind of work requirement you
can generate a temp instant template
from the VM who use the instant
templates all most likely the
configuration of the time machine have
the configuration of your VM so that you
can go back at any time without paying
any extra money because as the VM is
already deleted to get started it's also
simple just in as example shows an
g-cloud you can just simply provide a
source instance where while you're
creating the instant template so it is
another great tool to know - how to save
your configuration of a VM instance and
next obviously we want when we're
talking about the most important thing
is a backup your data on the disk you
probably know about a snapshot we
already provide a feature and that's a
great feature very high performance and
a space efficient offering the goo
already offer but you might want to ask
how can i periodically generating
snapshots well without any help from
Google you can use a cron job what
customers have been telling us is a ping
to manage especially - including delete
deletion know how to manage that and you
if you are one of the customers you'll
be really happy to find out Google now
will offer you the scheduler snapshot
feature what this does is exactly meant
to replace your cron job
what is scheduled snapshot support is
will support the frequency of creation
snapshots would be our day in the week
based and will also support retention
policy as the number of days you want to
keep the snapshot so you can simply
create a schedule looks like
Krita me a daily snapshot and the DDT
after 14 days very flexible to use you
can create a schedule and attach the
Moto VM motor disk so that you don't
have to do
that again again I read discs one thing
to call out this is the same the
snapshots created the same as regular
snapshots they're incremental snapshots
sometimes people call differential
snapshots what this does is it only
takes the snapshots of the Delta of the
change between the end time and n plus
one so you have a very minimal change or
even no change between or two times your
snapshot size can be very small so
you're now paying the whole disc size so
very space efficient performance high
performance and also price efficient and
you'll be very interesting excited to
find out this feature kind of available
for you for beta very soon so next I
would like to invite my coworker vibhuti
here also the lead engineer - who made
this feature possible to give you a
quick step-by-step guide on how to
create a scheduled snapshot as Sofia
mentioned now taking periodic backups of
your disk has been made really easy all
you need to do are two steps using our G
cloud first is to create a schedule in
which you specify a start time that
tells us the time of the day at which
you want the snapshots of the disks to
be taken and then you specify the
frequency for those snapshots and as
Sophia mentioned it could be hourly like
every hour every 12 hours
it could be daily or it could be just
certain days of the week and once you
create the schedule we also need to
specify some retention with max
retention days so that we know how long
to keep your snapshots for and after
those many days we automatically clean
them up for you once the schedule is
created you can add it to one or
multiple discs within the region and it
can be either done on an existing the
existing disk or it can be done while
you are creating your disk itself so
since these snapshots are created as per
the schedule so I can't demo
this thing instantly like Karen did but
for the demo purposes I have created -
[ __ ] - such red news
[Music]
so one is oddly with two days of
retention and another one is daily with
three days of retention as you see and
here I specify the start time to be 12
p.m. and let's see how this generated
snapshot are looking and I created this
schedule just a few days back like four
days back can we switch to the demo
please think of the second tab so here
and let me just filter by the disc with
a daily schedule and here we see exactly
three snapshots as my retention was
three and my frequency was daily if I go
into the details of the snapshots I see
the name itself has the name of the disc
the name of the zone where the disc
resides and also the time stamp so that
it's easy for you to read and know that
when the snapshot was created and as we
see the time matches exactly 12 p.m.
somewhere around 12 p.m. as it takes few
seconds to actually finish uploading the
snapshots and as we go back Sofia
mentioned our snapshots are incremental
I didn't change anything in those discs
for last 3 days so only my first the
oldest snapshot is a non-empty snapshot
and others are empty and you will not be
charged for the empty snapshots so
basically you'll not be charged for just
for creating the periodic snapshots
instead you'll be charged for only the
change that you make to your disc and
let's now filter by the disc with an
arleigh shade you'll and here you see
lot more lot more snapshots because
these are being created
every hour is you see by the name and
none of these snapshots are old the
oldest snapshot is also two days old
because I had specified the retention to
be two days
I hope this feature helps you to manage
your backups much better and thanks of
you thank you very great feature let's
switch back to the presentation
great so last point we want to talk
about about security how would you
secure the access to a VM instance how
can you protect the environment so there
are three things we would like to
introduce you in dissection the first
thing is the famous Identity and Access
Management or so called I am for the few
people that don't know what I am is I
will just give you a quick crash course
I am it's about defining who can do
which actions and war resource so that's
abstract right let's just have an
example so you could assign me Sofia
the instance admin role on to your test
project that's gonna allow me to
manipulate and manage your instances you
know test project but you did not give
me the same permission to your
production project so I wouldn't be to
do so on the production project right so
that's kind of fine control and access
control so with the newly released
resource level I am featur
now you're able to assign I am policies
on individual resources like VMs disks
what is allowing you to say common use
case will be I have a one instance I
would like to collaborate with you
troubleshoot with you but I don't want
to share everything else in the project
with you so I don't want to set a policy
on the project
instead I want to set I am policy on the
instance and you can achieve this by
simply as the example command shows on
screen you can set I am policy on the
particular instance and I will have the
four access to it with that I would like
to also give you guys a quick demo on
how this resource love I am work and by
the way this feature is also gonna be
available for beta very soon can we
switch to demo real quick
so for this demo purpose I have am using
a demo account I created and this is
myself who is the owner and that have
all the power to do everything the
project and I create another test
account which is David who also is
looking at my project but you can see
the difference as a project owner I can
manipulate all the instances he found to
start or stop them yet David as just a
viewer of the project he's not allowed
to as you can see if he's not allowed to
stop a VM instance or starts it he
doesn't have the permission he cannot
also SSH into it again no permission
right say there's a situation arises I I
do need now David to be able to SSH into
my machine to help me troubleshoot at
something I can go ahead and set a
policy on the particular VM that just
copy his username well great
1 2 3 4 5 6 let's copy his name and I
will go ahead to my console my view
which I'm the instance Adam I'm the
owner of the project I can go ahead set
the permission which is opening the side
panel and instead of adding the member
of him and give him the permission of
say instance Adam I go and add simply by
doing so I'm giving him the permission
to the particular instance that was 11
so let's go back to his view let's
refresh the screen his console and now
you can see this particular instance 11
he has a su gene and he has the
permission to stop or you know suspend a
VM instance so is that that's the
resource lava I am policy gonna be
available for your beta very soon let's
move back to the presentation and next I
want to mention is about how to protect
your operating system right how to
prevent people they're not authorized to
be able to SSH into your machine and
that is OS logins the feature you have
to learn there so before the OS login
feature available
the world was like the only way through
logging a VM is through setting the SSH
key on your VM instance metadata or the
metadata on the project level the
problem with that is as soon as the SSH
key is set there's no connection
whatsoever with the SSH key versus the
user so that's making managing the
access or revoking keys very difficult
so this employee could have her they
left your company but he still knows the
part you know the key value pair an SSH
key he can potentially still login to a
production environment and they expose a
lot of risk to you with OS login we made
a strong connection between the SSH key
and the user identity which I am control
so that user not no longer log in by
just the metadata set on the SSH keys
instead the user will log in with their
own identity with OS login we have two
roles available
I am ROS available for two assigned to
users os login which is the normal non
root access kind of the user and OS
admin login obviously offers root access
but no matter which row the users are
assigned to they were never login as
root they always log in as themselves so
that that is also making auditing very
easy later on and we also offered a
domestique add your actual API which
allowing the admins to manage and set
those SSH keys on behalf of users so as
a login great feature to manage your
operating system access and the very
last feature would like to share with
you to help with better access control
is organizational policy or policy our
policy is really designed to work done
by hand side by side with I am but the
key difference between IMS
Oracle policy has the enforcement
regardless this I am access for example
we have the first one no external IP or
policy see say if you said oral policy
on to the orga level and a set denied to
all the VM instance that cannot create
its own IP so then even your secure the
adamant the computer admin who should
have I am permission to create extra ap
will not be able to do so again because
the
forcement is there regardless of I am
permission so that enables you to
prevent human error also enable you to
prevent certain you know internal
malicious user of course we hope you
don't have any of those and there are a
couple more or policies you can utilize
you can send a VM instance trusted the
image make sure your limit you know what
images gonna developers can use you want
to make sure they only uses supported
versions disable syrup or access again
to protect your OS system so that no
insensitivity information can get out
from the zero console or I was dead
let's have a quick overview review of
what we have talked us so far
tune your instance scaling back up and
secure and if there's one message you
want to choose to take away from this
talk and that is Google offers a wider
range of machine types and features to
meet all your work color requirement
need well without any artificial
constraints and without you paying any
more and if you want to learn more about
compute engine their upcoming sessions
you can attend to just tomorrow and the
Thursday especially if you want to learn
more about security and the privacy and
I am I have another session Thursday at
1:00 1:15
[Music]